I made grogu's blue cookies from the
Mandalorian and they were so good
I'm not sure what the mandalorians call
these cookies in a galaxy far far away
but here on Earth we call them macarons
I decided to make Italian macarons which
uses cooked sugar that's incorporated
into the egg whites to make the meringue
giving a more stable structure than the
French ones macarons are notoriously
sensitive so I whipped in just a dollop
of blue gel food coloring and then
folded the meringue into the batter
macaron shells can be a bit Bland on
their own in my opinion so once I peeled
them I decided to fill them with a
chocolate ganache that I feel like grogu
would go crazy for I was fresh out of
bought the milk so I whipped up my own
using another small dollop of blue food
coloring then wrapped the cookies in
foil to mimic roku's silver packaging
and voila that's how